hey everyone welcome to this react js
full course video react is a javascript
library used to create fancy user
interfaces for mobile and desktop
applications
it is widely used and is preferred over
other frameworks for front-end
development
so if you wish to learn web development
then you are in the right place
this video covers all the necessary
topics to give you a good understanding
of react and some of its concepts
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what's in store for you
we'll begin with a quick introduction to
react and then move ahead with react
installation on windows
later we'll look at some of the
fundamental concepts like react
components
props and state
then we'll build an application from
scratch using react after that we look
at a comparison between javascript
frameworks like angular view and react
we're also going to be covering topics
like react.js with node
react with redux and understand what
react native is
we look at another detailed project
using react it will help you understand
the library better
after that we'll understand topics like
react hooks react router and then we'll
conclude the session by looking at some
of the commonly asked react interview
questions
now without further delay let's begin
in today's video we'll be learning all
about react.js so let's jump in and see
what's in store for us so we'll be
covering topics on what is react why
react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a
post-list component these components
make the code easier to debug and always
remain discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the webpage in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript and a familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website save
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create react
app version so you can see the version
here now let's continue and develop your
react application type in the command
create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created
your application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle alright to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks all right reusability is one
of the salient features of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components alright so
i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
sibling let me save it and if you look
at the browser you'll have hello welcome
to simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div and i enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again here you
go so multiple html tags have to be
enclosed within the div tag moving on
let's create a first functional
component to do that i'll first create a
folder in my source folder say
components within that i'll create a
file say
functional
component dot js all right so the first
thing we have to do is import react so i
say import react from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act.component so going
ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export per
file and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional comp let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
imported
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
com1 and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class com comma
class comp 1 and then again i define it
here class comp one let's compile it and
run it and here we go here you can see
hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence now i won't
get into the nativities of it because
they're advanced topics but to give you
a brief insight higher order components
are basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to 0. so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals this
dot
update
click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot count plus 1. okay and here we
say count times all right so once this
is done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot
state and here i change x to
com now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component now we import
higherorder.js in our counter.js and
click.js and pass these components as
parameters so let's do that let's go to
our counter.js and here i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say pureform.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag i'll display the text
say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regularcomponent.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use this snippet
our const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into a parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from pure component and then i say
import
regular comp from regularcom.js and here
let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot me now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
prop dot name and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply to set the state and
we're going to set the state for search
results to whatever is passed by the
system so the search results are going
to be returned as a callback and that's
what we store as an updated state now
coming to the add track method so let's
scroll up and we'll say add track and
this will take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot the
current state of all the tracks that are
there in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and add
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed in detail
is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state dot playlist tracks
those the set of current tracks that we
have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id which
means this particular track is not there
in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we're going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id
and then this is where we would want to
say this dot
set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making the change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track uh
is now the remove track and the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it
removes the track from the search
criteria so the search component which
is managing searching of the tracks it
will go and remove it from there after
adding the new track so that's a
combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and this dot set
state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot uri so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on uh spotify so that's the reason
we'll access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps
from a maintainability perspective so
even though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'll say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
music or file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject a search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we refer to in the css
file
we have another component called search
results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide
in other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is
search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be
6.94 rpm and
margin
bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
0 the border should be 1 pixel solid
white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge to give
a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll set up
the border radius then we've got uh
margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box so we change the outline to
none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
uh on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1 db 9 5 4. that
gives me color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got
a font family let's set up the font
family to the same standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to 0.833
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
uh transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up uh
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove in fact let's remove the
border we we would not want a border on
the button that would look odd so i'll
get rid of the border and color we'll
specify as per our standard color that
we've been using okay so that's the
color we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
uh the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case uh if we hover around
the button we would want
the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import
react from
react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot
css file then we define our class called
search bar which extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
we'll define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function and we'll have it bind
to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which uh we're also
going to pass the system define event
keyword so if there's any data flowing
along with the event we are interested
in it in this case the data is the key
code that the user is pressing and if it
is 13 that indicates that's the ascii
key code for the enter button so if the
enter is hit then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view and we return
the complete view here so that's the
view now that we want to return let's
say tiff class name equal to search bar
then on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
brace bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh we're
going to return a value i shouldn't
forget to export the search bar okay so
that's uh what i want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the button tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up our
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions uh that we
are actually written
uh so two things we've completed now uh
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks removing
tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
256
256
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s
border of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265
265 5 is the last parameter so that's
the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex
and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we'll
need a margin bottom of 0.22
rdm finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of 0.83
rem and a font weight of 300 and a color
as well that we'll add so let's add up a
color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css
and let's move to
the track and we'll move into the
javascript file so let's move into
so let me take what we added in the
search bar i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on
remove and this is the track that we
would want to go and remove we'll add up
another function called uh render action
so this is going to be a function uh
that we are defining called render
action and in this we'll just check if
this dot props dot is
remove
if this dot props
dot is
removable so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is
what it's going to map to
let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track
and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action uh
let's also have the return here
and we just add up the button and this
is going to add track so you can look at
how the component is completely dynamic
uh in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added this button with
the hyphen is going to remove the track
this button with a plus sign is going to
add the track and you can actually see
how simply it was done in a render
action function so the render action
function actually helped
with
checking that if
on the value of the props
and if the user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here is going to be
track dash information within it we'll
add h3 we'll bind to this dot props dot
track dot name so the name of the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot argo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream spotify.com
slash embed slash track and close this
so that's the spotify stream that we are
going to connect to and this dot props
dot track dot id so that's the track id
the width is going to be 300 the height
parameter this the height parameter is
going to be 80 of the iframe and
the frame
order is going to be 0 and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove a
new element okay and that's
what we can actually go and add up there
so let's check now whether
all that we've done is good to go fine
so everything looks good
in terms of the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now
which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much
so let's just say track
list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we'll need uh in the css
so let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot
map create a temporary variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to point to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we'll connect to we add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot prop start on remove so that's for
the track removal and
so we've got our track list
oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export
so we'll have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track lists and let's move on
to the next component now so we've got
app which is root we've got the search
bar that takes care of entering the
search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a track list that manages
a set of track records so the track is
more relevant to the playlist and then
we've got the search results also to
manage once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results and this is
going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero for pixels
2 pixels ash
and then
let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozad are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants and then we'll also add a
media query that if it goes with a max
width one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
with is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of 2r
okay so
we're going to add the hyphen so it's
hyphen webkit scroll bar zero pixel
width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the
js file now let's move to the search
results
js file and
that's where we will now have to go and
add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list add it up
here this would be
search results
and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list this will be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be
search results so that's the component
and this is going to export out search
results so it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props
dot search results
and on the on add we are going to bind
to this dot props dot on add so we
already have that so that uh basically
completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need uh to add up
to the playlist and uh i'm just going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just a css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css let me get
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get uh the
constructor in so
we'll add up the constructor here and
just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot
target dot value so we get the updated
playlist name coming to the render we
now need the input
input is going to be on change equal to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got uh track
list so track list is what i will add
the tracks i'm going to bind to this dot
props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to
do a quick look up
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in uh and create
an id it takes us to our dashboard uh
that's where we can create a sample
application the name of the application
will be musical file okay and uh we'll
say that we are building uh
some kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to connect this to and
we'll also need to provide
so we'll say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application
okay and we'll say save okay so that's
uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable that we'll create
is the redirect url or let's call it
redirect uri and that will equate to
localhost colon 3000 which is the port
and we'll create another variable called
the access token let's also create
another constant variable called spotify
and this will work like a function
expression so we'll equate it to a
function called get access token and we
will say if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot
href dot match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a reject expression to do a pattern
match ampersand so that we can actually
get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence uh the pattern match is crucial
here another constant variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edgex
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of one then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say
window.settimeout
and we're going to say access token
equal to comma
expires in multiplied by thousand then
we will say window.history.push
state and we will say access token we
pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter as slash and close this
and we will return access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say json
response
and if
not
jsonresponse.tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artists of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or not track uris dot len in that
case we simply return out of the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token and we create a user id and now we
will return the fetch result where we
will pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers
will be the header information then we
call the then function declare response
as a variable use the lambda expression
and access response dot json we use the
then block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to json
response dot id and then we return fetch
https
api dot spotify.com
slash v1 slash users slash dollar of
user id slash
playlist so this is how we've
constructed the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable to
response.json
then we'll create json response with the
lambda operation we'll create a constant
playlist id which is equal to json
response dot id we will return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers
variable be constant headers and this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we are going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and
the body is going to be json dot
stringify uris
track uris and we close this we close
this block we close this block and we
close this block so that completes our
code of course one more thing we have to
do which is export this class out so
export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is uh the client id that we'll
have to exactly match so i'll copy this
client id and provide it here so that's
the client id uh that we actually need
and we could also store it out here
so that's the uh client id and that's
the redirect url that we've also defined
there and we just create an access token
if your access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from uh
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here uh just like a data access
layer very similar to a data access
layer we've got a save function which
will save this data to spotify as well
so i've got a save playlist and i've got
search so these are the two functions
which will go and connect to the spotify
service uh by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data
and will then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist
now the results is going to consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
a confirmation link the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
uh that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available
from this artist and you can see the
plus buttons getting added on the fly so
that was the render action these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
if i go back to my dashboard of my music
file application and that i've created
here in the developers portal of spotify
on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches and can you
see here this is the new playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs that i'd actually added to
the playlist and you can see here those
four songs have got added out here okay
so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist uh the playlist has
got generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this uh with this
embedded web page inside the iframe
container so with that uh i hope we've
been successful with explaining the
concept of component based design and
architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that being
that you can isolate change request to a
certain component you can promote
reusability wherever you want the same
feature to be implemented on the page
you can just inject that same component
and the same implementation and the same
features can be reused so it promotes
reusability it promotes flexibility to
change it isolates your change request
to single components preventing the
massive effort of recompiling and
retesting the entire application as a
whole in this session we'll be comparing
the three cutting-edge ui development
technologies that is react.js angular
and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and
apart on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the salient features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the paths
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dorm
updation is time consuming risky and
error-prone vue also ensures faster and
bug free performance now let's talk
about data binding the core reason why
we would use single page applications
now consider a scenario where you'd log
into an e-commerce website as the user
one then you should be able to see the
items in your shopping cart while user
two would be seeing different items in
their shopping carts and so on so
identifying the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires a knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now view again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
jest is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these tags even deeper
all of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing there
were about 1 million repositories 5
million comments and 1 million issues
with respect to react here are the
figures for angular and here are the
figures for vue according to npm stat
over the past two years there have been
approximately 360 million react.js
downloads there have been around 38
million downloads for angular and around
63 million downloads for view now let's
look at the future scope learning a new
technology always comes with questions
like what's in it for me what's its
growth potential how far will it take me
in my career and so on so let's go ahead
and see the growth rate of react angular
and vue according to google trends over
the past 12 months react has been on a
way faster upward trajectory than
angular and view which have considerably
lost their momentum now this indicates
that react is growing faster than the
other two with respect to popularity
industry adoption and community support
welcome to this session on how to
connect react.js with node.js and in
this session uh we are actually going to
look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express.js application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
is now completed and let's uh go and
open up this project so i will say file
and open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up the
terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us a startup page the sample
default startup page for the first
client application and this is going to
work as a client we'll now go and try to
create
the backend
application which is going to be another
application that we will set up and to
create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will create
an express application on node.js called
api and let's give it some time for
installation okay so that's done clear
this screen we'll come out here we'll
open another instance of the editor
we'll say open folder and that's the api
application we'll say select folder and
the api application is opened let's go
to the terminal now in the terminal we
will attempt to install all of the
packages that are required that would be
logged in the package.json file so the
package.json file here would be a listed
uh so you can see we have a list of uh
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get we'll open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props
here i would pass props to the super
class constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to response dot text and
then we will again say this dot set
state api response
is going to be equal to the response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but a string which says api is
working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and load it we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name as app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
the return so we simply create this
application that's the react application
that will talk to this api that is and
this
url that is hosted on node communicate
with it get a simple string as a
response print that string inside this
react application so once that's done uh
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when we have actually gone and executed
the call api custom function let's go to
the api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross-origin module and
save indicates that it's going to do a
global install for all applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cars so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the cause variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i directly ping
the api that's hosted in node.js now we
are consuming it through the react.js
application and if you scroll down you
can see the message returned from
node.js into react saying the api is
working properly so the practical impact
of this is to actually host restful
services etc on node as a server and you
can go and consume the data that is
returned there could be in string text
or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux and what are those
pillars that drive what you're doing
redux and then finally what are the pros
and cons of redux and after we've gone
through the powerpoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo of actually using
redux so you can actually see how this
would all look so why would you use
redux well the reason why you want to
use redux is that redux actually
understands and helps manage the state
of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a
you know
take a
large application that you could create
with app with a react and breaks it down
to several components instead of having
this massive number of states you have
to manage and so every time that you you
know an application would then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the state and
this is a a really big problem because
when you're like doing that switching
back and forth there is the potential
for applications to be re-rendered which
reduces the efficiency of your
application and so this is why redux was
introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to match the state of
your tool uh you can actually use it to
work with any javascript framework or
library and you can actually then store
the um the application and the
components in a state store which makes
it easy to be able to manage the state
of your application so in simple words
redux stores all the state objects in a
single store and organizes it it
provides information about the current
state of the application any changes in
the state the application can be
described to the store by the user and
then it notifies any modifications made
to the state of that application so
let's jump into the key principles of
redux and there's three key areas i want
to focus on so the first one is that
redux provides a single source of truth
and that source of truth is uh being
able to store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect
components of your application uh also
enables you to be able to persist your
app state for development and improve uh
faster development cycles the second
principle is that state is read only and
that's why you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks uh would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions and
so what do we mean by this so we can
actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to a previous state
uh the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
um and there are four key
states there's get state which returns
the current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe
and these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state so an action is a plain object
that represents an intention to change
the state so with actions you have
payloads of information that send data
back and forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data
that can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a type field
that indicates the type of action that
has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are a reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make your solution really
optimized as an experience and then
finally developers can track everything
that's going on inside the app in real
time the cons
so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code
but
the component cells can access data and
they there is potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is um strict
in its um setup and it is memory
intensive so with that let's go in and
look at a demo of using redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node
version it's going to give me the
version number so that shows it's
installed and we'll also use npm which
is node package manager because we'll be
using that validate that it's installed
by doing node mpm dash dash version so
okay so looking good and we're going to
go ahead and create a folder um on our
desktop um normally you wouldn't put a
project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for
an experiment so we're going to call
this one
redux react it's going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being
taken through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd
redux react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax and we're going to do create
dash react dash app so we're going to
create a default react app and then
we're going to also install redux dash
app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to uh
build out our solution one is react and
it's react.js
and the second is redux and we hit
return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react
react-dom react scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so i'm
going to use visual studio code to do
most of our work here vs code
is an open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all the new
platforms uh it is from microsoft but it
is open source and
there's just a ton of stuff here but
we're going to go ahead and open up the
folder we just created on our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the
left hand side you'll see all the files
from that folder which is going to be
rid of the welcome screen we don't need
that anymore uh you'll see there's some
commands we use we do uh
control plus um i'm not sure what that's
called again anyway it gets us to the
terminal window um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
over here on the index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now
uh we're going to create a very simple
application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both um
just standard react and redux react it's
the optimization that's going to be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's going to take us to localhost
call on 3000 give it a moment and then
we should get our
floating uh logo showing that the
application's up and running up there we
are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called
new comp
dot js and we actually have some code
that we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
um so but we're just going to type in
here import react
and then component
from
[Music]
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the batch shop yes
and then rerun
npm
install
save
react
dash redux
and here we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the
using the store and reduces in redux
again the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in the
super props
and then this
state
equals
we have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app
don't forget to save your work as you go
along and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
make italics
then we're going to make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
i'm sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
we just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call we'll reference
this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be create dynamically use our
style
i'm going to add in a button
one
one-click
action
subscribe
and change too many s's
save that
all right let's see now let's run
that script
you're going to have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
get rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the news called js
component into here
player in
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again very simple little application
now playing from use code
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pull in two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and oop
let's see now oh yeah this is good
now we actually can show you that uh we
didn't actually write all our code
correctly so let's go back and fix that
because newport news
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
uh have a correct export feature here so
that the image that the
everything can be exported effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscribe to simplyline hit
subscribe and we change the text to
thank you for subscribing okay so let's
kind of go in and modify this now so it
goes from being a standard state object
to one that uses store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and since you reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go
to our index file
index.js
here's our react dom
now we're going to add
in contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and
we're going to
pull in
strict mode
okay juicer is not defined let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp.js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to props
equals
state
and i'm going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to type in
return
and we have our button
change
and for dispatch
we'll type in what the message
now we can have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as part of our export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here so serve to
button change we're going to do props
dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
[Music]
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
i'm going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and
con's new state
and
it's going to be
an if
action dot type
i'm going to change the message
says unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then
new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default and now we have the
new message
again this might seem like
extra work but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right now terminal window we're
going to do npm start let's see what
happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this again this is all part of your
standard coding is just hunting down
errors in your code
so let's go to index.js
and
let's say
we're gonna pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back recompile
let's
rerun uh
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be providing major
provider
store
[Music]
is referenced correctly
okay let's rewrite our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and it's able to then create the new
message again this is a very simple
application but you can see how for more
complex solutions how this becomes
useful and you start using the different
components you create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
hi guys welcome to this video on react
native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience it provides strong
developer and debugging tools with
meaningful error messages so working
with this tool becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook stack
overflow is an excellent website with
several developers interacting about
issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios and android devices there's
a huge user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform-specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform-specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform-specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform specific applications let's
look at some of the prerequisites for
building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong
holding programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and to lesser
extent classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native let's look at the basic concepts
like view state props and styling in
react native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters
these created parameters are called
props short for properties now props are
passed from one container to another as
a way of passing data between them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how you can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style
react native uses the conventional
javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed moving ahead to
our last and final section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native welcome
to this session on react native versus
flutter in this session we would look at
identifying some of the differences
between the react native and flutter
frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be that at the end
you should be able to decide and make an
informed decision as to which framework
is the best among those available let's
start from a language perspective now if
you look at react react is basically
completely written and built in
javascript using the react.js api on the
other hand if you look at flutter it is
basically written in a very new language
called as start and we do not have uh
too many developers that are skilled on
dart however
every browser and every platform being
shipped with uh an in-built javascript
execution environment that makes
javascript platform the language of
choice for developers so every browser
today or every browser manufacturer
would have inbuilt support for executing
javascript programs similarly most
popular platforms mobility platforms
like android and ios have default
support for executing javascript
programs and that's the reason when you
compare this with flutter flutter uses
dart which is predominantly a newer
language and we really do not have too
many developers who are skilled on this
so that really is the selling point uh
and the usp of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with means meanstag already working with
html css and dhtml can easily align to
this that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary
set of widgets
and it has its own page structure that
needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement third
party widgets and ui frameworks as well
now this is really what allows you to
pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
telerik controls or any other third
party ui framework can be implemented
but for flutter you have a pretty closed
ecosystem and that's the reason the ui
components that are available out of the
box and built into the platform are all
that you can use from a performance
perspective when you talk about react
native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flutter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on react native because in react native
it actually since react native is an
open ecosystem and allows you to
implement third party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and plug
and play and that's the reason uh the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh most developers would find
it a little challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always a key when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you obviously go to the
community to the community to go and
find out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
native being there for a while now it's
been around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css and building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of
developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and uh also
react native is part of uh github as
it's open source it was released in 2015
and it's because of the huge community
support that it becomes uh easier to
implement this you have a lot of
confidence as a developer when you start
building on this stack because if you're
stuck somewhere you will have a lot of
help available on the way on the other
hand if you compare that with flutter
you can look at the question count here
on stack overflow and this being a new
entrant in the market uh it has a
smaller footprint on the community
aspect but of course that keeps
increasing every day again from a react
native perspective and you talk about
stability in terms of stable releases
there again you would see that react
native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really move ahead on our
career graphs in terms of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in ide sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that
both these technologies
have been around react has been around
for quite a while and hence the job
prospects are much better a lot of
organizations implementing this clutter
has been a new entrant and hence uh
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg
you can actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flatter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not any longer required in
flatter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
in between the documentation much much
better in flutter because it's a closed
ecosystem and they can control what you
can use react native being open-ended it
really has a lot of third-party
integration you can do and hence the
documentation is not really well
organized the popularity perspective
react native much more popular among
html5 css three mer mean stack
developers since it's all javascript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that from a community support react
native has been there for a longer time
as compared to flutter and hence has a
stronger community support as compared
to flutter and that translates into
better job prospects
in the industry for react native as
compared to flutter so if we were to
give it a score react scores much better
with a total score of five leaving
flatter with a total score of two so i
hope we were able to understand the
differences between the react native and
flutter and this will help you make
better decisions with planning your
career and deciding which technology you
should latch on to
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so we'll be using javascript
to be installing react and installing
the various components such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see the calculator
works just fine and now let's go ahead
and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms uh it comes with a ton of
extensions so you can get up and running
really quickly with it
so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to download
it again you also want to make sure that
you have the latest version of node.js
installed now with that node package
manager so we're just going to open up
our terminal window and validate which
version that we have running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node
version and it'll tell us which version
and which means that's installed and
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to
do that and we're going to also now
create a react app so we're going to do
install and then it's going to be create
dash react app that's the command to
create a new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and that will take a few
minutes just to install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be disabled
on the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have
our new folder right there
on our desktop but we're actually going
to go now into visual studio
and if you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to work with the
node.js in visual studio code
because i can run terminal window right
there so i'm going to open up the folder
that we just created
go calculator and we open up the whole
folder um not a file but the whole
folder and here's our folder on the left
hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default
element
as you can see because we're using react
it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div with the id of root that's
going to reference um some
class files that we create and so the
app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to
our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross-referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's have localhost and
everything running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so uh see
now yep everything's running where we
expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the airport
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go
site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in
and
we're going to just restart
our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default react app
coming up on port 3001
there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
we'll put in default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
i'm going to call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
layout
components
layout you necessarily have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that
so dot upon folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows to add the js
extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css let's give you a css file that we're
going to create
so we're going to have to type that into
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
[Music]
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we'll go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our path in here just
quite quickly
so
let's see now
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
rerun this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
um yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we are okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that it actually starts
pulling in the application
and
put in the class name for calculator and
this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a css file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but
as bottom line is that the calculator
really is
a bunch of form elements
um such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same button elements
which consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on-click command um this is some basic
javascript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete
now we have an i'll click event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
make sure everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so let's
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just going to copy everything over
just make it a little bit easier
ourselves
and then we're just going to find pin
the numbers
7 8
9
and then
plus symbol
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really
complex it's
just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen start seeing
all the different elements
okay i can get it
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
so
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do then our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the for the sake of brevity
we're just gonna pull those over
um
we can
if you want to um and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create the csc css files and
um you know we'll certainly do that but
i think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the watercolor et cetera et cetera
and so i'm going to do that
here we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
default logo
so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets and the assets will put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
just reference that in our image
reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we go to amg which we
have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the has the
import of the image
i'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
don't generally normally do this i
normally have all my styling in my css
folder um but uh in this instance
because we're just putting up a solution
i want you to be able to see that you
can actually do this in line so there we
are how about simply that logo
okay so now we need to have the
results screen make sure that looks
correct
okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to go to our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and
now put row
put yeah instructions here so we're
going to like export
default
output row
um
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct our solution
i'm going to update the output row.js
file
and
we're going to
add in our return value
so put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field um
that will be read only at the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here
and
that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to give our formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output row.css
we're going to add in our specific css
for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and
let's go over to our
style it
will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default
value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will
pull in our output row
and the value will be
[Music]
we bring our text size for output flow
here
and we're just going to put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
now we have two
rows
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm gonna
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
we have to
pull that font over
and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our
font so that the second row the text is
a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment i'll be easy part of this
assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net
input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the results
the you state
the initial usage will be just blank
there we are
just what you'd expect to see
so the results
um are blank and this is just when you
run the app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
we want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base react application
putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images
fonts
css files
um laying out our course structure in
html form elements
and now um the part that we're doing at
the end here
is putting together the script that will
actually
write they'll actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
and there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error a result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
[Music]
so our different results
so depending on
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign
and
you have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll capture our value and this is
all concatenate together
and
[Music]
if there are any error messages
so if the value is
c from the button so if you select c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset the screen
and
if the value
equals
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard
javascript control
so hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
and
put if the string is
zero then put
that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay
want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
and then we'll put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands all your variables lining
up correctly
eliminate those
now we'll make sure we have the answer
and the user
entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we'll go over this is now this is our
local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see
everything lined up correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we will restart the services
say yes
i'm running on another port because we
already have an app running and another
port says to run on 3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good
working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
make it a native application as well
right now we're just using as a web
application
and we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything's looking exactly the same
there we go that's your app
all up and running hello everybody and
welcome you all
so
we're gonna talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is once called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens when
we work on react-based development
so in react 16.8
we have introduced a new feature called
react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks
we were writing so much of code because
of that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down
okay and we have actually increased the
productivity of our development
now how the react hook really changes
the way
this we're gonna see it now in those
slides
now what are the react hooks see the
react hook is a special feature that
lets you
hook intro
now what is this
see they say few important things they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
straightforward logic without changing
your component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay so hooks let you use most of the
react features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle
management but not always you need these
two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards the
state
less or functional components so by
adding those hooks feature so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you'll be having some
add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks
so there are few rules of the react
hooks which you need to understand
and what those are
number one they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hooks only call hooks from the
react function component don't call
hooks from the regular javascript
function instead
you can call hook from the react
function component or call hooks from
the custom box so there are multiple
options are available which you can
expose or use in your regular
react-based applications
okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used straight hooks eventbooks and
create customized hook and we will see
some demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
going to start working with another type
of oxy
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
even based hooks we're talking about
something called use effects so how the
usefx really works let's take a look now
so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can so
let's use one property called props here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
props dot
count so my question is like what do you
mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name call
extend dot
default props
default
props
okay equal to i'm starting with the
curly braces
and after this curly braces here saying
count okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we're giving count
initial value equal to what a zero now
and uh post this
this value whichever we are giving it so
what we also do in the same line is uh
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and uh
this way i can say set count count plus
one okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npm space start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was 0
that's why if you see initial value was
zero so now because of getting the
initial value called props dot count and
now i can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say minus one and this value
rather than saying count plus one
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hook is of an option
which is available called life cycle
hooks
life cycle hooks are very very important
that means you're trying to say
whenever you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to launch
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it
so how you're going to be making it now
let's take a look now so initially what
i'm doing is
i'm just
creating a new function called
use
because it is a predefined
okay available from
okay react 16.
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property
from react and under this use effect
what i will do is i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see this thing called every time
even if i say increment it is getting
called even decremented is getting
called and reset it will get called
because this is a life cycle method
and the life cycle method means it will
get called
normally in a react we have a call
component dead mount and component date
update so it is a copy of both
okay
however
you can
stick this particular use effect to the
specific need only like if you do not
want this to be get called
on updates only when the component
launches so what you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this square bracket will contain those
values which you would like to watch for
those changes
so if you do not keep it anything by
default it will be what blank so now if
i just go ahead and start it is saying
called every time and now you can say
it is not getting called at all because
now it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching
not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not
every time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect and
say called
on
update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see the state is getting
changed for this count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling
like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the count and this you
are not listening to anything so you are
making it as apply
i hope you are clear about what use
effect is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
state hook where we have seen use effect
we have also seen another feature that
is called use state and now we're going
to be talking about our next okay
everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is called use context
see when we talk about react use context
we always have a very special feature
coming up with us where the reusability
comes as an priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about the option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem and
then we discuss about the solution so
now here
i'm gonna say uh use
context.js and in this use context.js
what i'll be doing it i'll be creating
some few functions here i'm saying
function
okay
so in this manner i can create
const
i can say
user
set user equal to
use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app user set user
uses state admin
and now after this
i am using return
and in this return
with my div tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name call
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise if i want to share the data
to the other components how i basically
try to use that's an important thing i
would like to consider right now so this
is my first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this
i can copy
and see
user 2
for this function i'm creating this user
tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
user as in parameter
okay so return
you can define it anything i can say
paragraph
in this i can say
[Music]
user to
component
okay and i'm saying
component 2 and now i would like to pass
this value further to the another
component now
so what i'm trying to say now here
if i say user 2
let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here
i'm defining this value called
user3
okay space user
equal to
user
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where
i'm trying to use this functionality
so we are having this function user2
okay so after this
we are taking function three and adding
the data right over there
okay so this dev tag
whichever you're taking it
so we have a called main app we can say
user two and forward per user three so
the data we can keep on passing from one
component to another component
so we have got this component with me
user two and same time we have called
user three now
okay and this user two whichever is
available to me okay when you're saying
hello user
this user too i can provide this data
right over here
okay so in my main application i can say
uh
user
two
okay and with this we can provide the
value called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what you'll be doing because
we are passing the data just like that
but the only thing is what if this main
app
wants to pass the data directly to the
user three it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user
three only from its immediate child
which is a user 2
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default uh the name is called main app
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
app.js
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome admin welcome
so that's pretty fine
components are basically rendered but
there is no reusability if you see like
it is a
plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
app context equal to
create
context
okay so we're going to say equal to what
a create context
so as usual the states are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this
context so anyways i'm having this dev
tag
so i'll be using this option like in
user context
or the context which we have created
that is called context so we are saying
what
app context here okay dot
you see there's an option available
called provider this is the one which
will be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay and this app context
i would like to cut it
and paste it after here
okay and here
user to use it to whatever it is the
value is there so you are passing it to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whosoever wants to access your
context it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap this second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
video to the user3 also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so
let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay
so
you're saying value equal to what
user here
so after that you're saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it okay and
say use context.provider
okay and the second component
when you say user2
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove it
okay and the same you can remove it from
here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected
okay so that becomes the idea of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay user f is basically what the use
ref you can say it is the kind of hook
which allows you to persist value
between the renders
again i'm telling you users allows
actually to persist the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable okay that does not
cause
a rerender when updated
okay
that means
you can persist that value in a storage
okay as a mutable value which does not
cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example
so you all can understand how we can
utilize this
okay so i'm gonna create another one
here
name call use ref dot
js
inside this use ref.js so let's get
started with this implementations the
one which we're looking at right now
so called user if so once again i'm
creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use
ref you can see it is coming once again
from the where from the react here in
this user we can pass initial value
black we do not have initial value so
that we are sending it as a what is a
blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
prep value
okay dot
current
equal to
input file
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
to be get updated so we are passing
input value for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i'll be
saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
dev tag
and here in this step type we can say
input type
equal to
text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying on change
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready i
just want to use the
s3 tag
to show what is the current value we can
say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 we are saying
last value of
we are saying
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what
the kind of value you are actually
expecting into your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist
use reference value between the render
so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name
of app and this app i'm using it here in
my app purchase
app
let me terminate it and
launch it again
[Music]
let's see
local 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure
we'll be able to see the outcome
soon into our system so now you can see
these values are coming up so now when i
pass the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value and i said three it
containing the previous value when i say
for it holding the previous value
that's where exactly the beauty of this
user of which you are expecting it from
all of you so everyone we have already
seen like our previous example like how
we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in hooks
continuation to this and that we're
talking about call working with a use
reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer
is again a hook which is as same as like
an user state
okay it allows for custom state logic
unlike the normal state how we maintain
using your state allows to help
having some custom logic also see if you
are finding yourself where we have
called multiple portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contain
the centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can really do this and
how we can utilize that so in hooks demo
i'm going to create a new file here i'm
going to give the name called
not
app.js
and in this node.js i would like to have
some initialize state i won't like to
make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic call
const
note reducer
note
reduces equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like a normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use a
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition client so client is ready to
invoke i'm using action
dot
type
okay
and here we use the first option like in
case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate underscore
whichever existing nodes are available
populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
dot
notes
okay or else in a default case
or in a default case we are saying
return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of
states are available which i would like
to show it back to the client so we are
using this option like it
cost
let's create a states first we are
saying const
nodes
comma
dispatch equal to use
reducer and inside this rule is user
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken it
is an action here
and comma the initial state which i am
making it is a blank
i do not have any states of making it as
a blank again i am using this option i
can const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank so that's
how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check
in my code
how to basically
display the list of nodes back to my
application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write
okay so let's check in case if i want to
return
the bulk of nodes how do i do this
so here
let's try to create
the
notes app so
this i would to make it
that was a reducer for us
now here we're going to create cost
[Music]
and i'm closing it here
okay so we are having these two
properties with me
and
we can have a number of actions also
but let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the div tag
inside this tab tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
notes
dot
map in case if i'm having a array of
notes map is a predefined function
for me so here we are using what
not
okay so
so inside this you would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so
i can use the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
you can just use
the default sheet which is available for
nodes
equal to what notes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
the data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is
and here
under this we would like to provide
note
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
note app
and this note up i'll be making it as a
child of app.js
okay
you can see i have got initial data
displaying here
so in case if i have few more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see our god
list of records are available to me
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you are clear about
what in case if i want to use
uh you know this reducer
so how we can further utilize it to
initialize
the data with this but later on if i
want to some add some actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like uh
how we will be utilizing
our
you know use reducer applications now
i'm gonna tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular tool so what is the
user memo it is again another hook
so
use memo hook returns some memorized
value what was the previous value was
so we can
say think of
uh
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value within that
so use memo only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function
okay so it is
use memo can be used to keep expensive
and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running
so we will see how this
use memo can work
so let's check this out and see see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
calculations so that it doesn't need to
run unnecessary every time
okay so it does a kind of caching
behavior for you to make your life even
more simple so let's see how it works so
accordingly you will also get the
implementations
okay so
you need to understand the use memo hook
except the second parameter
okay to declare dependencies so the
expensive function with only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
okay so inside your memory app.js what
do you do is just take a look let me try
to close rest of those
yeah so here you see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say zero
for a time being i'm trying to use now
okay
and uh
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform
this job only okay count and set count
according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
cost to do
equal to use state
i'm making it as a what type area type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation
equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal to
set count
c
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to dos here
okay and use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added
so three functions we are basically
calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i am having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another tip tag here and here we're
using
my after this h2 we would like to use
todos dot
map
slash what index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here
sorry
equal to what
index here
and here
to rules
[Music]
okay
who do you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say one click and in on click
we'll be calling
at task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so here after this
div tag is getting closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another tip tag
here
and here we are seeing
count
and here we are using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here
and call something called
calculation
just like a normal message and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done
so your dip tag is also close
both the trip tags are getting closed
okay and they are also getting close and
now
we would like to
perform one function whichever i would
like to use it for my
standard calculation
okay so let's see what we are trying to
do
so here i am saying
power running calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button insert this lock button i'm
saying
calculating here and post this
this thing is called
for let
i equal to zero
i is
less than
okay and we're using what
i
plus plus
and say
num
equal to 1
okay
and after this
i can say
return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memoir
that's it
okay
so this would be my application here
okay so
now
here in this example the expensive
function which is called long running
function
okay
whatever i'm talking about
the long running function
okay will only run when the count is
changed
and not when the totals are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we're using this statement
and uh
here
we're gonna give the name of this
long running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here
so
in this application
hooks accept second parameter to declare
dependency this exp so the long running
functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's a whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay
so that's what the whole picture of what
we have done so i'm sure like you all
are clear
about how
this memo is really performing some job
the one which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay
and uh
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is what's called
use imperative handler it is again a new
concept as we have already seen multiple
different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look when we talk
about use imperative handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use imperative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the later which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends
because it allows again it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling
and customizing the return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're going to start working with a
very simple approach
into our code okay
so we're going to create a new one that
is called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js and after this we are
writing
function
converter
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props and seconds call what
two parameters we are passing it now
here we are saying
const
user if
okay
now
after this we're using use
you can see we have called use
imperative handler comes from
one so we are using this use impellative
handler and here we are passing what
refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality called blur
okay and here
with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
custom blur is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return
we are saying button
okay
and with this button
i want to use rift
okay equal to
btn and
props we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay that's it and
once it is done then
we would like to use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application system
so once it is ready i would like to
make it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here you are passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here i will be making it as a child
off but
[Music]
in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memo app so here in my application
i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we are passing
null here and after this
this value whichever we are having it
which is set cut
and passing it here
and this under this written keyword i'm
using
button
and in this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second
yeah
so inside this button using
on click
equal to
we are saying btn
okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here
okay so we say
import
button
which class we have created here
imperative demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
so we're providing what btn.current
blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
btn
that's it
so this is where exactly the
options are so you understand in this
particular example we have developed a
custom button component that has a user
defined instance attached to the
reference object
attached to the what the reference
object now so we have developed a button
component that has a user defined
instance attached to the reference
object so button component is a child
component of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here
the button is clicked
okay it called
user defined blur function which is
attached to the pass reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't tried anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
so under here
okay
so now
okay so
here
the things are working the way we were
expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now
we are now
using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
use comparative reference so we have a
call function button
we are passing two parameter props and
ref so we're getting this use reference
object
and use imperative we are passing this
ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as in the kind of custom objects where
console.log custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and you're saying dot dot props
click here button and export default
forward reference button here
and followed by app.js
we are just using this
normal app component
const but in equal to use reference null
return we are returning this button
one click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot
current dot blur
and uh after that is getting close using
f equal to what btn whichever you're
referring it and that's it so the job is
done
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all dawn
loading is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all norm
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dock
but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise it will
block
so the use
layout effect
okay works in the same phase as
component did mount and component did
update methods we should only use use
effect
layout effect if use effect is not
outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example the one which you are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're going to give the new file name
called use
but yes
okay so let me add
constant
layout
okay
and here we're using cost
equal to
use state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
welcome
i am saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log an insight is saying
use layout is working
okay
with value so
using what the value here
okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the values to
okay so we say
return
inside this tip we will say
value
that's it
and after this
left
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
here we need to check
[Music]
so a value okay all right so here i need
to use
to make it okay so now
i go to the inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see it is loading
synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it is expected
used out is working well that is working
to the react it's perfect so that's
where the idea of this particular
example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the use layout
effect is called
okay and it working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value
this is once again another hook
of the react based development
so when we talk about use double value
so what use double value actually does
and
what we
really do with the use debug value this
we would like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value hook okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the debugging custom books so use debug
value is a simple in-built hook that
provides more information about the
logical of a custom mode within a
reactive tool so react dev tool is a
tool which you can
get it uh downloaded for your chrome
extension
okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react
views debug values basically be useful
for
now how you basically use this so you
can just consider in this way uh if i
just go back and create a new file
and give the name called used value
use
double dodges
okay
so inside this youtuber.js
here we would like to use function
and in function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
id
and here we can use const
yes
online
set
online equal to
user state
we are providing the value called what
okay and now here we use this option i
can what use
debug value and here i told you is
online
question mark
here we say
online
okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
default
trendline online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you're looking for
so this is very popular and utilized and
useful option for the regular users
hello everybody and welcome you all
so today we have a very interesting
session coming up for this react which
is called react router so let's get
started with react router and see what
it offers
so friends the first important thing
about what is the routing
as we know it very well the routing is
synonyms of
navigation
any application whether you talk about
multi-page application or single page
application it always requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
uh you know to be navigate from one part
to another part like you have called
login page registration page and you
have got a lot of links available
and when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through
okay
now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js
based application which is you know it
is designed for developing a server-side
java based javascript based applications
and on react net which is once again for
mobile based environment for react
applications
now react router components so browser
router so typical we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
api so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something
from where
okay it uses the traditional html5
history api which is one of the main
component so
it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes
so routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate root will get loaded for you
so-called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like
ahrefs how we used in html pages
so
to different
uh from the traditional react replica
application so it is mainly designed to
focus on navigation throughout the
applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have
first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create reactor so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook
and the router hyphen tutorial is the
name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen now to hyphen dom so this
dependence you need to install
post
first
uh i would say the message is executed
so once the first command is ready then
you will be going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
dom so this is how the steps are
and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on
so i already have a project ready with
me which we have created with using
create react app so my project name is
react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new
uh
router based example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already installed so if
you see this package.json react router
dom is already there in place so we
would like to start now developing those
router based examples so to make it
happen what we will do is here in my src
we will create a new folder named
components
okay and inside these components
we will create some file name called
login dot
js
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
one more
name call
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay out of which i want the first
components to be get launched here that
is known as call a landing page so here
i will also create
landing page.js
so let's go back and create a new
components here which will be helping us
to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have a call app.js which
is a
base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new
functional component so i just copy the
same
and here in login.js we paste it
and give the name to
login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component i copied
and i pasted in the portfolio
so you call portfolio welcome to
portfolio
register
register
login you know called user retails
okay so we have got these components
with us
i will start with
landing page first
so
i would like to create a class-based
component here
so
import
to react
from
react
now
4d4 class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return
okay so this is
the one we call tube tag here
well
this is my component which is available
to me
so the landing page is a component which
through which i'll start working on
so
[Music]
i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside so
what i will do is
this landing page in my index.js
i'll make it as a first component to be
launched
landing page
so when i start my application i should
see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect
so this has become my first component
which i
want to launch and furthermore we would
like to add few more components here
okay so in a previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a
learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
syllable landing page we would like to
create some more
dependency we are saying import
from
react hyphen router hyphen dom so we
will be choosing those dependencies one
by one but from there we want to start
working with
cons routes
equal to
first thing
as we discussed with you that is we
would like to start with the browser
router
okay
so
from this point onwards if you like to
start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is
login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
here it says c small
component equal to
okay
it's not loading so we can say import
and since i want to launch
the component which is a type of login
so we can say import
from login
so if you see here
we will call login so we will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
i would like to say
login
and in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration
we copy the same
use this
register
register
so this is how the components are used
here
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called login and
seconds for register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it under this
div tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and
here will give the name call
routes
that's it
so once this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs
so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
[Music]
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import it out from this page
now let's go back
okay nothing is shown so now we have to
manually type by saying
login you can see i've got this message
for welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register
so two components are loaded correctly
now we would like to import two more
import
portfolio
portfolio
okay
and last
we have a call a user details
name call
user details here
so we got user details let me copy these
two
so
register portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now we can see all
the registered successfully
well in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible
so i will be doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is
like here itself you create a new
component called
header
okay
so this is how we're going to create the
new component called header
okay
so within this
you're going to add
the new
tag called header within this you will
be using
nav link which is once again
the tool provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within the snap link you will provide
the option like in two
equal to
login
and
along with this
you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
register
we also have call
last we have called
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router
we would like to add the component call
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see
how these are easily accessible to all
of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that
this component whichever we are talking
about okay
this component we can attach
to one of my
base component when my components start
it should work automatically so i can do
one thing like my login component to be
the base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exact equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's how
your url works
okay everybody so in the previous
examples we have seen how the links are
working but these links are all internal
links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point so here let me try to open up
i'm opening up simply learn link and i'm
clicking on this
the url is right now https
simplydone.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and
[Music]
here
if you want to go to that location so
what do we need to do now
so to make it possible here i can just
make this another nav link
copy the same
then i give the name call
simpler
and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it is asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i am making it as a blank
okay and here
i want to give window
dot location
dot
href
equal to
the website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i'm
providing it now
and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that'll be the link
so i'm saving this and going back to
this
location now so you can see we have a
call simply that the moment i click it
here
so
it will somehow try to take me towards
where
this external website the one which
we're actually looking forward for
okay so this is the way
through which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and uh
[Music]
refresh this and click on simply learn
and you can see now it took me to an
external location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply do
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the link
which is available right you can see
right now we have got
multiple websites so if i just click on
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more and i say
simply learn youtube
simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided i'll just copy this link
and
paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
i can see simply learn youtube i click
it
and you can see it took me two way to
the right
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically
they are created available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
welcome to this session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature which helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes uh updating
and incorporating change requests
to the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only built to read
regular javascript objects and jsx is
not a regular javascript objects it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called people which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is an api created by w3c and it
creates an in-memory representation of
the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic dom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
dom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view or the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there's no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the the base javascript entity
class is changing and that saves a lot
of uh processing time again to debug
react is much more simpler and that's
what makes it more popular in terms of
its simplicity and speed as compared to
other frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
european computer manufacturers
association or ecma and all of the
scripting languages are a subset of the
standard and are derived from these
standards to ensure that the code will
execute on all browsers and the code
that we are writing is standards based
so these are the few instances where es6
syntax has changed from es5 if you look
at the es5 first syntax at the top we're
creating a simple react class component
and the render function just returns a
stream of html content in ex6 there's a
new keyword that comes in which is
extends so you are extending from the
base uh react component and creating a
custom component and then returning a
stream of characters also the function
keyword no longer needs to be used so
the exports versus export also changes
so you use exports to export out class
from a module so that it can be accessed
from another module in es6 you simply
say export and the component require
versus import so you would require a
third party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react apt using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action can be triggered by a user or any
system or could be pressing a key or a
mouse click etc and in response to that
event you would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standards based
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to or the html template where on
click we connect to this event handler
called handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand an on
click sun another browser would
understand a click and to ensure there
is consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the list display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names uh
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through an iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys in lists so keys are very
important in the code snippet that we
saw due to the following reasons the
first reason the key is a unique
identifier if you would want to search
for a name in the list it is used to
identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform cloud operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend
react.component we create a state
variable this dot state is equal to
value we handle the change by writing a
handle change event and we handle the
submit by writing a handle submit event
in the change event we just change the
state by saying set state of the value
to event or target dot value event being
a system defined keyword passed as a
parameter and in the submit we simply
alert that a certain name was entered
and we trap the value that was entered
into the form prevent default to
suppress the browser from raising any
errors on the render function we return
a form on the submit we connect to the
handle submit event and we bind the data
submitted from the form to the handle
submit event and we pass the this
pointer which is a reference to the
current context of the view itself we
open a label specify the name we then
specified input box as text the value is
set to this dot state dot value and on
change we simply connect to the handle
change event and bind to it and pass the
context of the text box itself so the
moment we change the value in the text
box as we are typing the handle change
event will receive the updated value and
set the state and when we click on the
submit button the handle submit event
handler executes and we alert out the
current value printed in the text box
and that's it so how do you write
comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash asterisk to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we've created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the bike so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of 150cc
and to access it if you look at the
import statement we are importing app
from
app.jsx and this is how you can
cross-access properties from one
component within the other so what are
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read-only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom uh we simply go and render
the app component so hello simply learn
would be the final output and that's how
you can embed one component into the
other using this methodology what are
the differences between class and
functional components so stateful
components would extend react component
in this case and if you could look at
the render it simply renders
this.props.title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props the div tag returns
this dot props dot title so you can look
at the style very different in terms of
class and functional components one
using the arrow operator one using the
traditional class and render method so
the class component can hold or manage
state complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any life cycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
life cycle methods of components we've
got kenish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application
store contains state which defines the
user interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a rear router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route defaults out it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this style output how do you style react
components using a css style sheet so
here's an external style sheet so we've
written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css is the extension the
css inside a module file is available
only for the component that is importing
it so there are no naming conflicts so
dot button is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the
button.module.css file and so with that
we come to the end of this detailed
tutorial on react.js
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you